Hawaii five-o graced our screens for
many years but that's recently come to
an end in February twenty twenty it was
announced that the tenth season would be
the last for the popular show so why did
the series come to an end and what did
it have to do with star Alex O'Loughlin
well a lot the catastrophe catastrophe
how is this a good thing
a report by deadline offered some
insight into Alex O'Loughlin who
portrayed Lieutenant Commander Steve
McGarrett and his time on the show
pointing out that it's not the first
time the actor has considered calling it
quits as recently as a couple of years
ago it was speculated that the actor who
was known to be having physical
difficulty with the show's demands and
suffered a serious back injury pretty
early on in the show's run would depart
fortunately he opted to stay on
following a successful round of
stem-cell treatment there is no way a
good conscience I can walk away from
this one at this point however a
locklins body was telling him to quit
and rather than replace him with a new
partner for Scott Caan's Detective
Sergeant Danny Danno Williams the series
creatives decided that it was simply
time to hang it up after all can anyone
really see Dano running around with a
new partner late so it gave me breakfast
daddy
that's funny round even kidding
the rest of the cast may have been
fairly fluid throughout the past ten
years but the two leads have been
together from the beginning sometimes
it's best for shows to pull the plug
rather than push on when they hit a wall
and losing one of their main leads would
certainly constitute such a wall Oh
Lachlan spoke two years ago on his
possible departure to TV Line pointing
out how things had changed since the
show's beginning he also describes the
proverbial laundry list of injuries he
sustained on the show ready for this one
a lock when said I've blown both
shoulders one me I've had my elbow
tendon reattached
I've got bulging discs in my neck and my
back I don't know where to start
I'm a mess and a lot of it's been really
really hard I think back to when I was
doing most of my own stunts in the first
few years that was not a great idea
but the physical exhaustion of working
with injury and working huge hours day
after day year after year the whole show
has been extremely physically daunting I
don't know how much longer I can do it
after the announcement that the show
would be ending a Lachlan shared a
message for fans he said this show has
been pretty much every waking moment for
the last 10 years of my life everywhere
I go on this planet in every language
I am McGarrett to all these people what
we've done what we've accomplished it's
extraordinary
I can't really put words to express my
level of gratitude I'm just glad to have
been a part of this a part of history
and I'm going to miss it in to the fans
I don't know how to thank you guys thank
you for following us the way you have
I'm going to miss you Aloha while
networks may allow visionary creators
and talented actors the freedom and
budget to make exactly the kind of shows
they want to make television is still a
business broadcast networks like CBS aim
to turn a profit by selling advertising
space on its programs if it spends
millions of dollars each week on a show
that isn't bringing in the big audiences
that it promised advertisers and for
what it charged accordingly then that
show is likely to get cancelled this is
a big reason why long-running shows
leave the air when they do as they no
longer attract a big enough audience to
justify its costs
McMahon I don't know I don't know when
it happened with something changed in
regards to ending Hawaii five-o
showrunner Peter and Len Cobb told TV
Line I think the network just thought it
was a good time there are so many
different things that factor into this
economics everything in other words the
ratings for Hawaii five-o had dropped
over its decade on the air at its peak
of popularity in 2015 the show averaged
12 point two eight million weekly
viewers by the 2018-2019 season that
figure had dropped to just over 10
million and the first episode of the
tenth and what would turn out to be the
last season brought in just over 7
million pairs of eyeballs despite
several factors indicating that Hawaii
five-o was moving toward a close in its
tenth season producers made plans for
the future just in case CBS did decide
to bring it back for one more round of
episodes the final two installments of
the show added a brand new character
ex-marine Lincoln Cole portrayed by
recurring MacGyver actor lance gross
Steve McGarrett even asks him to hold
down the fort in the event of his
absence showrunner Peter M Len Cobb told
TV Line quotes I thought he would be a
great addition to the team
and he called Cole quote the perfect
sort of broken toy to complement the
team in addition to moving : to focus
the last episode of season 10 which
became the Hawaii five-o series finale
had initially been written to set up
some eleventh season plot lines but when
Len Cobb learned CBS ended the show he
had to make some cuts
he explained quote I have 12 minutes of
that show that are not in there that are
on the cutting room floor Peter Lang qov
one of the main brains and producers
behind the popular show specifically
mentioned a Lachlan in his statement
when the cancellation was announced
another clue that the actor is the main
reason why the show was coming to an end
he said my eternal gratitude to our cast
led by our hero Alex O'Loughlin the
writers the production team our CBS
Ohana and most importantly you the fans
who allowed us to come to work with
pride and made our series such a success
David Stav the president of CBS
television studios had shared that fans
could expect a big send-off with a quote
opportunity to say goodbye to their
favorite characters fans indeed got that
in the two-hour April 3rd series finale
there was action emotion and intrigue
aplenty and even a few surprises though
the show might be over its run was a
success that will be cherished for years
to come by fans around the world check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bells
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]